there's something very special about
Tekken you know it's it's that 3D space
um it's one thing that I was a little
like I have to I have to get still get
used to right and for me from back in
the day it was like okay there was
Virtual Fighter as the most grounded
fighter and then it was Tekken to me
where it was like the mov fell yeah the
the the the moves were grounded with you
know within reason obviously we were
fighting against pandas and you know
whatever but the mov set still felt
relatively grounded in like real
martials or whatever but like to like
you alluded like the anime of it has
increased exponentially right